So let's go back again to our domain, with
all the sub-domains identified. And the basic idea, or the
intuitive idea I was talking about, is that errors tend
to occur at the boundary of a domain, or a
sub-domain. Like in this case. And why? Because these
are the cases that are less understood by the developers.
Like for example, the last iteration of a loop, or
a special value like zero for integers. So if this
is true, what we want to do is to select inputs at these
boundaries. And this is complementary to partition
testing, in the sense that partition testing
will identify the partitions in which we want to select inputs, and boundary
testing. So the selection of boundary values
will help select inputs in these partitions.